how close to you because we were talking
about the hair
is russian doll
can you talk to us about this show that
is so well respected so well loved
critically received you know nominations
yeah what do you think it is as like the
creator of it thanks true also just
thank you oh that's true uh
yeah it's an interesting thing i mean
i'm always very moved that
they even give us you know like the
money to go investigate these these big
questions you know there's this uh
victor frankel book uh man search for
meaning man searching my favorite book
yeah so
uh so i remember like bringing that into
the
the writer's room on the the first day
of the first season and saying like all
right so this but half hour comedy uh
there's you know
but i guess the stuff that i draw on is
almost more
uh parable or sort of life experience or
almost like spiritual experience in a
way it's it's oddly almost a
theological show except by way of
science as opposed to theory and i
i'm so curious about
things namely the first season is really
asking the question you know how do i
stop dying and the second season is
really answering the question how do i
go about living
that is so cool
how do i go about dying how do i go
about living yeah so
so yeah i was really curious about that
so you can read these books you go to
the yoga classes and you hear about
ramdas and you go to the shrink and they
tell you you know just be here now and
you know the thinking feeling person
really says but how yeah and i i just i
was like oh my gosh now we can actually
explore that let's dig into those
questions and see what we find well i
think now i know why it's such a success
um and um i just love you for exploring
those subjects and for your honesty and
your journey and your curiosity as you
so brilliantly put that's so apt um and
um i'm just so happy and excited for the
success of whether it's the orange is
the new black and your life and the show
and i just i'm so happy for you and i'm
so excited for season two how do we
start living i love that question it's
so profound
it really is
and i'm ready to
i'm ready
all these new ways i love getting older
by the way growing up is not overrated
bad it's the greatest oh my god the best
what a what a false bill of goods
they're like oh be careful because it's
the best up here i completely yeah i
know i only get better and better i was
such an idiot back then i had fun yeah
it was fun it was sometimes
sometimes not everybody's idea of fun
yeah i had a great time yeah i don't
regret a thing but god i love growing up
and getting older do you know what's a
real sign of for me of getting older too
i my perfect afternoon or evening is
like hanging out either with friends or
by myself but i with my kids i've always
got the crossword with me and i heard
you're a crossworder
that's my whole life
i love the crossbars all i care about
the cross oh
i built one for the new york times
you built i built a bus with a wonderful
woman deb amblin we built it together
yeah it would be incredible will you you
should make a crossword i would love to
make a crossword and i'm very excited
because i'm going to work with this guy
matt gaffney who does the um week
magazine and the new yorker and he's
doing um a crossword for our next issue
of a magazine i started called drew it
has my name on it um but um but that
content sounds terrific but the the the
um
he's gonna do the crossword it's like
meeting your marvel superheroes like
thor's in the other room and you get to
meet him so but will you do a crossword
with me this would be a dream
[Music]